okay we've got a voicemail number that
number is two one nine two david p let's
take a listen to what the Eggman said
now this is the Eggman is saying
something that a lot of people wrote to
me and they said David you you were
supposed to be keeping hey tree at mail
guys name a secret but you accidentally
said his name yesterday during your
segment about it and I am convinced that
I didn't and the egg man's voicemail I
think explains to us what the
misunderstanding is dude I don't know
what's the bigger revelation here that
you called out your voiceover guys name
as Pete that's the first little crumb
that we get and also why the hell is
Pete listening to right-wing radio dude
what's going on there man
yeah so the hatred mail guys name is not
Pete but five or ten people wrote to me
and then said they said hey David why
did you name Pete as hate reott mail guy
I thought you were supposed to keep his
identity secret I think I said he
because the the guy's name is not Pete
and I didn't say his name and I also
didn't say Pete so I think it must just
be I said something that sounded like he
right yeah I heard he when we did it
live but after this controversy started
up I took a look at the clip again and I
could see how some people may have
thought you said Pete yeah said he but
you know Pete Peters a pretty common
male name so there is a chance I guess
that uh Patriot mail guy's name is Pete
even though you try to brush that off
yeah it's not it's not Pete and of
course it could be but it's not and I
think really the bigger apology is not
to hate rip mail guy but it's actually
to Dana Loesch because it turns out that
she has been doing these hate mail bag
bag bag hate mail I forget what it's
called anyway she's been doing what we
identified is suspiciously similar to
hate mail for many many years so my
suggestion that she copied it from us I
take back I don't know if she's been
doing the deep voice announcer intro all
that time but she very very angrily
tweeted me and a lot of her followers
were dogpiling me on twitter so you know
what she independently developed the the
hate mail bag concept for her show we
developed our version which we call
hatred mail I have no reason to believe
at this time that anybody plagiarized
anybody and I apologize I was wrong and
it's not about what the meaning of the
word is is
I was just wrong there's no caveats I'm
not apologizing if anyone was offended
Pat I'm just straight-up apologizing
because she didn't copy it from us at
least not in its original form and I'm
sorry I made a mistake having never
heard her program before hey tree mail
guy you know what we have revealed
actually hey Triet mail guy is very good
at reading hate mail he's not so good at
segment production and that he ended up
actually proposing a segment to us which
led to me having to apologize today so I
think he owes us a few maybe extra hate
reott mails we have a great bonus show
for you today we will talk about
yesterday's primary results we will talk
about Miss America scrapping the
swimsuit competition how upset is Pat
about that and we will also talk about
the swatting of parkland student
activist David Hogg all of those stories
and more on the bonus show join
pakman.com to access the bonus show
instantly